an alarming new spike in the coronavirus
and the growing political fight over how
to stop the spread among younger
americans
now according to john hopkins university
the nationwide average of new daily
cases
doubled in the last three weeks with the
south hit especially hard and yet
the top health official in tennessee
says she's been fired
amid reports of a republican pressure
campaign to stop promoting vaccines
for teenagers in mississippi multiple
children are now in the icu there
omar villafranca is in jackson that's
the state capital you know that omar
good morning to you
we keep hearing that mississippi has one
of the lowest vaccination rates
in the country that's not good
good morning gail the large majority of
people
in the hospitals here in mississippi are
unvaccinated people the state has the
lowest vaccination rate in the country
only about a third of the population is
fully vaccinated
and now doctors are saying that's
putting children at risk
across the state of mississippi seven
children are now hospitalized with
covid19
fighting the dangerous virus in
intensive care units two
are on ventilators when you have younger
kids who are now getting hospitalized
what do people need to take from that so
what we're hearing is this is a mix
of kids with underlying conditions and
then some that were previously healthy
dr jennifer bryan
chairman of the board of trustees at
mississippi state medical association
says children are more at risk when
vaccination rates are
low in this phase of the pandemic
there's really two life choices
it's to vaccinate or you're going to get
covet it is that contagious of a virus
in tennessee the state's top vaccination
official dr michelle fiskus
says she was fired this week after
suggesting some
teenagers could get vaccinated without
parental consent
this delta variant is is beginning to
bear down on us that we know is more
infectious and infects children
more significantly meanwhile the
tennessean says it obtained emails and
an internal report from the state's
health department
that claim it will stop vaccine outreach
to minors for all diseases
not just covid amid pressure from
republican lawmakers
in a statement to cbs news the tennessee
department of health said
we continue to support outreach efforts
and that it has
in no way shuttered the immunizations
for children program
we are simply mindful of how certain
tactics could hurt that progress
but as kids get ready to return to
classrooms in a few weeks
fiskus said she is worried the risk of
covid will only get worse
so they're going to go back into schools
with no mask mandates
and no protection from a vaccination
we talked to dr leah smith she's a
pediatrician who leads the covid
outreach at her church here in jackson
mississippi and she tells us the
toughest people to convince to get the
shot
younger people but she says that the
spike in cases of children in the icu
could act as a wake-up call adriana
let's hope so omar thank you so much